Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
KEEP YOUR PANTS ON
'CAUSE THIS PARTY'S
JUST GETTING STARTED.
WE'RE TAKING AIR-CONDITIONING
INTO THE GREAT OUTDOORS.
I KNOW YOU MIGHT BE THINKING,
"OH, YOU'RE JUST SOME GENIUS."
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
PUTTING IT ON
COULD NOT BE EASIER.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
COME ON!
GIVE US AN OFFER!
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
INSTEAD OF INSULTING HER,
LET'S CLARIFY SOMETHING.
I'M NOT INSULTING HER.
YOU GUYS CAN ARGUE ALL DAY LONG.
THE PROOF IS IN THE SALES.
Narrator: THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
THAT'S NOT COOL.
...OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I GIVE MY MONEY TO PEOPLE THAT
WILL DIE FOR THEIR BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY.
WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP.
BULL CRAP.
Cuban: NOT BUYING IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS RIDICULOUS.
HE IS GOING TO KICK YOUR...
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS WHAT
THE ENTREPRENEURS BELIEVE
IS A MORE FUNCTIONAL VERSION
OF A WORKOUT NECESSITY
FOR WOMEN.
♪♪
SHARKS, WE ARE SO EXCITED
TO BE HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS SARA MOYLAN.
AND I'M HER HUSBAND, BOB MOYLAN,
AND WE'RE FROM MICHIGAN.
I'M THE CREATOR
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS OF...
Both: SHEFIT.
WE'RE SEEKING
A $250,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, SHEFIT IS THE ULTIMATE
SPORTS BRA.
WE ARE THE FIRST
AND ONLY FULLY CUSTOM
ADJUSTABLE SPORTS BRA
ON THE MARKET.
YES, I SAID IT --
FULLY CUSTOM ADJUSTABLE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
PUTTING IT ON
COULD NOT BE EASIER.
SIMPLY UNZIP IT
AND PUT IT ON LIKE A JACKET.
NO NEED TO BE
A CONTORTIONIST ANYMORE.
THE SHEFIT SPORTS BRA
IS THE ONLY BRA
TO HAVE A TWO-INCH-WIDE
BUST SPAN
THAT WILL NEVER
STRETCH OUT, ROLL,
OR ALLOW YOU TO FALL OUT
THE BOTTOM AGAIN
WITH OVER 10 INCHES
OF ADJUSTABILITY
FOR YOU TO SET THE RIB FIT
THAT YOU WANT.
AND VANISH THE BOUNCE
FOR GOOD
WITH EVEN MORE
ADJUSTABILITY
FOR YOU TO SET THE VERTICAL LIFT
THAT YOU DESIRE.
SHEFIT IS THE PERFECT MIX
OF COMPRESSION AND ENCAPSULATION
SO THAT YOU'RE
ALWAYS COMFORTABLE
AND YOU NEVER
HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT DREADED
UNIBOOB AGAIN.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, SHARKS,
WHO'S READY TO BE A PART OF
THE NEXT BIG THING IN FITNESS?
YOU ARE SO NOT IN SHAPE.
WELL, HEY, YOU KNOW,
I TRY. I TRY.
IS SHE ALWAYS ON
LIKE THIS?
ON POINT.
[ LAUGHS ]
-ROBERT, THIS IS YOURS.
-SHE'S ON POINT.
Herjavec:
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE BROUGHT
EACH ONE OF YOU
YOUR OWN PERSONAL
SHEFIT SPORTS BRA.
LORI, OF COURSE YOU GET PINK.
THANK YOU.
I'LL BE USING IT
AT THE GYM TONIGHT, SARA.
YES, YES, YOU BETTER.
YOU BETTER.
[ CHUCKLES ]
KEVIN, THIS IS THE PERFECT
FIT FOR YOU.
HE ACTUALLY
DOES NEED A BRA.
OKAY. DAYMOND.
AND MARK...
THANK YOU.
...THIS IS YOURS.
APPRECIATE IT.
LORI,
ISN'T IT A LITTLE THICK?
Greiner: I JUST WAS GONNA
ASK YOU THAT.
THIS DOES FEEL VERY PADDED.
Sara: YEAH.
IT IS VERY THICK.
IS THERE A REASON FOR THAT?
YEAH, SO, FIRST OFF,
I CREATED THIS
OUT OF MY OWN NEED
FOR A SPORTS BRA.
SO I'M A FITNESS
PROFESSIONAL.
I HAVE FOUR KIDS AT HOME.
-DAMN.
AND WHEN I WAS PREGNANT
WITH MY FIRST,
I WAS TRYING TO STAY IN SHAPE
AND DO ALL THE RIGHT THINGS,
AND --
-YOU HAVE FOUR KIDS?
I HAVE FOUR LITTLE GIRLS
AT HOME. ALL GIRLS.
GIRLS.
[ Chuckling ] WE BOTH DO.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO, YOU KNOW, I WAS DOUBLING
AND TRIPLING UP ON BRAS.
I MEAN,
WHEN YOU ARE BIG-BUSTED,
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET A SPORTS BRA
THAT FITS YOU
THE WAY YOU NEED IT TO BE.
SO, ARE YOU SAYING WHEN YOU WEAR
THE TRADITIONAL ONES,
WHICH ARE, LIKE, REALLY, LIKE,
A REALLY STRETCHY NYLON...
LIKE A SPORTS BR-- YEP.
...THEY SMASH YOU.
YEAH.
SO THAT'S WHY I HAD SAID...
OKAY.
...YOU KNOW, IT GIVES YOU
COMPRESSION AND ENCAPSULATION,
WHICH GIVES YOU THE SHAPE
OF NOT HAVING THE UNIBOOB.
AND THE ZIPPER HELPS, AS WELL,
SO KIND OF --
-[ LAUGHS ] WHAT'S A UNIBOOB?
-A UNIBOOB?
-THE UNIBOOB IS THE SMUSHED --
-WHAT'S A UNIBOOB?
-THAT SMUSHED ONE-BOOB FEELING.
-ONE BOOB.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU PUT ON
A COMPRESSION BRA
TO TRY TO COMPRESS THE BOUNCE,
IF YOU WILL,
IT SMUSHES
EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
YOU STANDING THERE,
IT DOESN'T LOOK BULKY ON YOU.
-NO. MNH-MNH.
BUT IT'S SO PADDED
THAT I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU WOULD LOOK BIGGER.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE PAD
IN YOURS?
I DON'T. I TAKE THE PADS OUT.
SEE, THIS IS WHAT'S SO GREAT.
IT'S REALLY YOUR BRA,
AND YOU WEAR IT YOUR WAY.
BUT ISN'T IT UNCOMFORTABLE
BECAUSE IT'S SO THICK?
WELL,
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION.
IT'S NOT UNCOMFORTABLE.
SO WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
GET THIS PRODUCT ON,
IT IS SO COMFORTABLE.
IT'S LIGHT.
ALL OF THESE
ARE WICKING FABRICS.
IS THERE ANY OTHER BRA
OUT THERE
THAT ZIPS FROM THE FRONT
LIKE THIS?
IS THIS STANDARD?
-YES, A MILLION.
SO, LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
THERE ARE SPORTS BRAS
THAT ZIP FROM THE FRONT.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE A PATENT
ON OUR ADJUSTABILITY.
IT'S A UTILITY PATENT.
-ON WHICH ADJUSTABILITY PART?
Bob: BOTH OF THEM.
ON THE SHOULDER STRAP
AND THE BUST-BAND COMPONENT.
-THE TWO TOGETHER?
-THE TWO TOGETHER.
IT'S A VERY STRONG PATENT.
NOBODY ELSE HAS THIS TYPE
OF TECHNOLOGY.
NOBODY IS GIVING YOU --
YOU MEAN THE MULTIPLE
ADJUSTMENT TECHNOLOGY?
ABSOLUTELY. NO, AND NOBODY HAS
IT THE WAY THAT WE'RE DOING IT.
BUT LET'S GET PAST THAT.
YES.
BECAUSE THE PROOF IS IN
THE MARKET AND IN YOUR SALES.
EXACTLY.
SO TALK NUMBERS.
WE'VE DONE $220,000 IN SALES
IN 18 MONTHS,
$50,000 OF WHICH HAS BEEN DONE
IN THE LAST 45 DAYS.
$25,000 OF IT WAS FROM
OUR E-COMMERCE STORE.
MM-HMM.
THE OTHER $25,000,
WE OPENED UP 19 RETAILERS.
IS IT ONE CHAIN?
-NO.
-NO. MULTIPLE.
-WHAT TYPE OF RETAILERS?
OKAY, LET ME -- CAN I?
THANK YOU. [ LAUGHS ]
SO, BECAUSE THAT'S ONLINE --
[ IMITATES ENGINE CHUGGING ]
I WONDER WHO DOES THE TALKING
IN THE FAMILY.
I KNOW.
HE CAN NEVER GET A WORD IN.
-WE'LL LET YOU TALK AGAIN, BOB.
-WELL, WAIT. LET'S CLARIFY.
INSTEAD OF INSULTING HER,
LET'S CLARIFY SOMETHING.
I'M NOT INSULTING HER.
WELL, YOU'RE SAYING
SHE DOES ALL THE TALKING.
MAYBE THERE'S A REASON.
-I THINK SHE DOES.
John:
SHE JUST DID ALL THE TALKING!
[ Chuckling ]
SHE DOES DO ALL THE TALKING.
MAYBE THERE'S A REASON
SHE DOES ALL THE TALKING.
Sara: SO --
WHAT IS YOUR ROLE?
WHAT IS HER ROLE?
I'M -- I'M ALL CREATIVE,
ENGINEERING, SALES.
BOB IS MORE THE LOGISTICS
AND FINANCIAL.
I DO THE -- I DO MANUFACTURING,
WORKING WITH
OUR OVERSEAS VENDORS.
DO YOU DO THIS FULL-TIME?
WE HAVE SALES JOBS BY DAY.
AND SO -- JUST TO BACK UP
A LITTLE BIT --
WHAT KIND OF SALES
DO YOU DO?
SO I DO MED-DEVICE SALES. I --
I'M INDUSTRIAL CHEMICALS.
-AND YOU HAVE FOUR KIDS.
-AND I HAVE FOUR KIDS.
-AND YOU HAVE THIS BUSINESS.
-AND YOU BOTH WORK OUT
LIKE CRAZY.
THAT'S CLEAR.
-WE DO, YES.
YOU HAVE TO, CHASING AROUND
A BUNCH OF KIDS
AND HAVING A WIFE
THAT'S SUPERWOMAN OVER HERE.
YOU GUYS ARE AMAZING.
BOB AND I HAVE BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL
AT OUR DAILY SALES JOBS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THAT SUCCESS
HAS COME A TON OF FREEDOM.
AND I'M WALKING AWAY
IN LESS THAN 90 DAYS.
'CAUSE N--
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
IN LESS THAN 90 DAYS?
YES, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU'RE GONNA GO FULL-TIME?
ABSOLUTELY.
WHY DO YOU NEED A SHARK?
WHY DO YOU NEED $250,000?
THE BULK OF THE MONEY,
ABOUT 70%,
IS GOING TO BE
TO FUND OUR INVENTORY.
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW,
WE NEED TO SHORTEN OUR LEAD TIME
AND INCREASE
OUR SUPPLIER RELIABILITY.
WE NEED TO ENHANCE
OUR FRONT END, RIGHT?
FRONT END?
FOR OUR WEBSITE.
SURE.
WE HAVE SUCH AN AVERAGE
FRONT END.
THAT'S BEEN ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES,
IS WE CAN'T GET A WEB TEAM
TO GET THINGS RIGHT.
RIGHT.
SO THE AMOUNT OF SALES
THAT WE'VE DONE, YOU GUYS,
I JUST NEED TO BACK UP
AND TELL YOU,
HAVE COME LITERALLY
FROM WORD OF MOUTH,
GRASSROOTS MARKETING,
ME HUSTLING,
PICKING UP THE PHONE,
GOING TO TRADE SHOWS, AND...
FACEBOOK ADS.
...FACEBOOK ADS.
THAT'S IT.
WHAT DOES IT COST TO MAKE?
THAT BRA RIGHT THERE
IS $14.50.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
$58.99.
-$58.99.
-THAT'S A GREAT MARGIN.
NOW, HERE'S THE THING, THOUGH --
75%.
LISTEN TO THIS, THOUGH.
THIS IS THE THING.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE WERE PAYING --
I BET YOU HEAR THAT
ALL THE TIME.
"LISTEN TO THIS, THOUGH."
SHE'S GONNA HIT ME
IN A SECOND PROBABLY.
I KNOW.
WELL, WE WERE PAYING --
WE WERE PAYING
ALMOST $40 A BRA
TO MAKE 'EM HERE IN L.A.
THEY COULDN'T KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND.
WE WERE SELLING OUT
WHEN WE GOT THEM IN.
YOU GUYS,
THIS IS A $3 BILLION INDUSTRY.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS GET
INTO THE ACTIVEWEAR SPACE.
ACTIVEWEAR FOR WOMEN
IS A $15.7 BILLION INDUSTRY.
WE'RE GOING OUTSIDE OF THAT PIE
AND WE'RE CREATING OUR OWN PIE.
THIS DOESN'T EXIST
RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU'RE NOT CREATING
YOUR OWN PIE.
NO.
CUSTOMIZ--
CUSTOMIZABLE SPORTS BRAS
DO NOT EXIST.
BUT YOU'RE NOT, SARA.
SARA, YOU'RE --
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE GOING AFTER
THE SPORTS-BRA INDUSTRY.
BUT CUSTOMIZABLE.
THEY'RE OUT THERE.
YOU'RE DOING IT BETTER, MAYBE.
DOING IT MUCH BETTER.
EXACTLY.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING
OUTSIDE OF THE PIE.
WELL, IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
THOUGH, ROBERT,
AND I DON'T MEAN
TO CHALLENGE YOU,
BUT EVERYONE'S DOING
"ADJUSTABLE" SPORTS BRAS.
IN TERMS OF ADJUSTABILITY,
IT'S LIMITED.
WE ARE CUSTOMIZING -- THIS IS
A CUSTOMIZABLE SPORTS BRA.
NOBODY ELSE ALLOWS YOU
TO CUSTOMIZE YOUR OWN FIT
HERE AND HERE.
LOOK, THE POINT -- YOU GUYS
CAN ARGUE ALL DAY LONG.
SPORTS BRAS --
THE PROOF IS IN THE SALES.
-EXACTLY.
PROOF IS IN THE SALES,
THAT'S RIGHT.
EXACTLY.
WE'VE DONE -- WE'VE DONE $50,000
IN THE LAST 45 DAYS.
WE HAVE 200 ONLINE REVIEWS
OF WOMEN,
WE AVERAGE 4 1/2 STARS
BECAUSE THEY LOVE IT.
SO, FIRST OF ALL,
I ADMIRE THE DISCIPLINE
TO HAVE FOUR KIDS
AND TO BE
IN THIS INCREDIBLE SHAPE.
I MEAN, HEALTHY BODY,
HEALTHY MIND, RIGHT?
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT YOU'RE GONNA CREATE
A BRAND-NEW CATEGORY
OF WOMEN'S WEAR,
YOU LOSE ME THERE.
I'M OUT.
AND THAT'S A FAIR --
THAT'S FAIR.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THAT
ADJUSTABILITY,
IN TERMS OF SETTING
YOUR OWN SUPPORT,
DOES NOT EXIST.
AND THE SPORTS-BRA CATEGORY
IS HUGE.
I JUST NEED SOME DOORS
TO BE OPENED.
GET ME IN FRONT
OF THE RIGHT PERSON,
AND I'LL SELL THESE BRAS
ALL DAY LONG.
I BELIEVE THAT.
LIKE,
THIS IS A BIG THING.
OUR RETAILERS --
RETAILERS HAVE TO STOCK
ANYWHERE FROM 12 TO 14 BRAS
PER CUP SIZE.
32, 34, 36, "A," "B,"
"C," "D," AND SO ON.
"B," "C," "D," "E," "F."
OUR BRA,
BECAUSE OF THE ADJUSTABILITY,
CAN GO FROM,
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS...
AND THEY STOCK SEVEN SIZES.
...TO THIS.
SO NOW WE'VE DRAMATICALLY CUT
THEIR SKUs IN HALF.
AND I'LL TELL YOU --
-OKAY, THAT'S INTERESTING.
YOU'RE REDUCING THE SKU COUNT.
-ABSOLUTELY ARE.
AND THE AMOUNT OF INVENTORY
THEY HAVE TO HOUSE.
AND I'VE BEEN SITTING HERE
THINKING ABOUT,
"WHAT HAVE I SEEN OUT THERE
ON THE MARKET?"
SO YOU GUYS HAVE SEEN THINGS
THAT HELP YOU WITH YOUR POSTURE.
YEAH, I'VE SEEN THEM.
THEY ADJUST HERE, RIGHT?
THEY BRACE ACROSS YOUR BACK.
-THEY BRACE IN THE BACK.
THEY CRISS-CROSS ON YOUR BACK
AND THEY HELP YOU TO KEEP
YOUR SHOULDERS BACK.
YEP, AND THEY --
THE ONLY MISSING FEATURE IS,
IS THEY DON'T COME ACROSS HERE.
WELL, THAT'S A BIG DEAL, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHS ]
-IT'S A HUGE DEAL.
-WELL, BUT IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL,
BECAUSE IN PATENTING,
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING
THAT IS PRIOR ART,
WHICH I WOULD IMAGINE
YOU MUST HAVE FILED THAT.
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING,
THEN AN EXAMINER
MIGHT LOOK AT IT AND SAY,
"WELL, IT WAS INTUITIVE THAT YOU
WOULD PUT THIS INTO A --"
Cuban: YEAH, BUT SOMEONE'S
GONNA CHALLENGE YOU...
-"YOU WOULD PUT
THIS INTO A BRA."
-...AND GO THROUGH A WHOLE --
Greiner:
SO THAT CONCERNS ME.
AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE A PATENT
OR YOU'LL LOSE YOUR PATENT.
I'M JUST SAYING
FOR ME AS AN INVESTOR,
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS OUT THERE
THAT MIGHT BECOME PROBLEMATIC,
I'M OUT.
THAT'S FINE.
AND WE RESPECT THAT, LORI.
THANK YOU, LORI.
WE DO.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
HOWEVER, WITH APPAREL,
DAYMOND,
YOU KNOW TO GET A PATENT
ON APPAREL IS VERY HARD.
YEAH, SO, YOU KNOW, I ALWAYS SAY
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA CREATE
ANYTHING NEW
IN THIS WORLD AGAIN.
YOU KNOW, TWITTER WAS A NOTE
ON A PIGEON'S LEG
A MILLION YEARS AGO.
I DIDN'T CREATE ANYTHING NEW
WITH A T-SHIRT.
RIGHT.
I HAVE SPEED TO MARKET.
I FOUND A NEW AREA
THAT WAS BEING NEGLECTED.
MM-HMM.
I THINK I CAN ADD VALUE
WITH SPEED TO MARKET.
I-I REPRESENT JILLIAN MICHAELS
FOR INTERNATIONAL LICENSING
AND A LOT OF THESE INFLUENCERS.
-MM-HMM.
SO I'M GONNA TAKE A SHOT.
BUT YOUR VALUATION
IS A LITTLE HIGH.
YOU WANT $250,000 FOR 20%.
I WANT TO BE 1/3 PARTNER.
$250,000 FOR 33.33%.
-OKAY.
THAT'S A LITTLE RICH,
ISN'T IT?
BUT YOU HAVE TO GIVE ME
THE ANSWER NOW.
THIS GUY IS ASKING
FOR 1/3 OF YOUR BUSINESS.
WHY DO YOU WANT TO GIVE UP
ALL THE EQUITY --
GUYS, I NEED THAT ANSWER
RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I LOVE
DECISIVE PARTNERS.
♪♪
WE'D LOVE TO ACCEPT
YOUR OFFER.
-AH.
-CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
-WOW!
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-THAT'S FUN.
-DECISIVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT? NO, NO,
I'M NOT GONNA SHAKE --
I'M A HUGGER.
-FAST.
-REALLY FAST.
WE ACTUALLY KNEW COMING IN
WHAT OUR MAX WAS
AND WHO WE WANTED TO
DO BUSINESS WITH.
SO I --
YOU WANTED TO DO
BUSINESS WITH ME?
I DO. WE DO. WE DID.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
GOOD JOB.
WHOO!
OH, MY GOSH.
[ Laughing ] I'M SO EXCITED!
Sara: WE GOT A DEAL
WITH DAYMOND JOHN,
AND THIS ALLOWS SHEFIT
TO JUST RUN FASTER THAN EVER...
EXPLODE.
...AND EXPLODE
WITH JUST CRAZY SPEED.
WE'RE SO EXCITED.
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A MODERN VERSION
OF A COMMON ACCESSORY.
♪♪
WELL, HELLO THERE, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS JEFF POPP.
AND I'M CASEY LORENZEN.
WE'RE FROM DENVER,
COLORADO,
AND WE'RE THE FOUNDERS
OF CO.ALITION.
WE'RE HERE SEEKING
A $200,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR 20% EQUITY
OF OUR COMPANY.
NOW, SHARKS,
WE LIVE IN AN AGE
WHERE EVERYONE
IS CONSTANTLY ON THE MOVE
AND TOTALLY ADDICTED
TO THEIR TECHNOLOGY.
WHEN YOUR PHONE DIES,
IT'S LIKE THE WORST
THING IN THE WORLD
AND YOU'RE LEFT SCRAMBLING,
TRYING TO PLUG YOUR PHONE
INTO AN OUTLET.
WELL, NOT ANYMORE!
'CAUSE CO.ALITION BACKPACKS
ARE THE SOLUTION.
WE GIVE YOU BRAINS
AND BEAUTY
BY INTEGRATING SMART TECHNOLOGY
INTO ELEGANTLY DESIGNED BAGS.
WITH OUR BAGS,
YOU NEVER HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT YOUR DEVICES
RUNNING OUT OF MEMORY, DYING,
OR LOOKING LIKE A DORK.
WITH OUR SYSTEM, YOU SIMPLY
PLUG YOUR DEVICE INTO YOUR PACK,
AND YOU HAVE CHARGING WITH YOU
EVERYWHERE YOU GO.
[ CELLPHONE CHIMES ]
-UGH!
-[ LAUGHS ]
-OH, I'M OUT.
-[ WHISTLES ]
-OH, THAT'S IT, I'M OUT.
-SWEET.
WHEN IT'S TIME
TO RECHARGE YOUR BAG,
YOU DON'T NEED TO
REMOVE ANYTHING.
JUST PULL THE CORD OUT AND PLUG
THE PACK DIRECTLY INTO THE WALL.
NOW, WE KNOW YOU GUYS
ARE READY TO START THROWING
YOUR MONEY AT US,
BUT JUST KEEP YOUR PANTS ON
'CAUSE THIS PARTY
IS JUST GETTING STARTED.
WHAT REALLY SETS
THESE PACKS APART
IS THE INTEGRATED
WIRELESS HARD DRIVE.
WITH THIS, YOU CAN STORE
THOUSANDS OF DIGITAL FILES
SUCH AS MOVIES, MUSIC,
AND DOCUMENTS.
IT'S LIKE A PERSONAL
CLOUD SERVICE
THAT GOES EVERYWHERE
YOU DO
AND KEEPS LARGE FILES
OFF YOUR DEVICES
BUT WIRELESSLY ACCESSIBLE
AT ALL TIMES.
NOW, DON'T BE INTIMIDATED
BY OUR BOYISH GOOD LOOKS,
BRUTE STRENGTH,
OR PRISON TATS.
THE FACT IS, WE HAVE THE PASSION
AND DETERMINATION
TO MAKE THIS
INTO A GREAT SUCCESS.
NOW, WHO'S GONNA HELP US ADVANCE
THE EVOLUTION OF CARRY?
WE HAVE A COUPLE BAGS RIGHT HERE
YOU GUYS CAN CHECK OUT.
AND THEY'RE WIRED UP
WITH CORDS.
TEST IT OUT.
Greiner: THANK YOU.
[ CELLPHONE CHIMES ]
SO, HOW LONG HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN DOING THIS?
OH, COOL.
WE STARTED THIS BUSINESS
ABOUT SEVEN MONTHS AGO,
BUT WE HAVE BEEN
IN THE PACK INDUSTRY
FOR ABOUT SIX YEARS.
Lorenzen: WE HAVE AN EXISTING
PACK COMPANY.
IT'S AN OUTDOOR TECHNICAL BRAND
CALLED MHM.
DOES THAT COMPANY
STILL EXIST?
THAT COMPANY DOES STILL EXIST.
IT DOES, YEAH.
HOW BIG IS IT?
LAST YEAR'S SALES
WERE $450,000.
IN TOTAL, WE'VE DONE
$1.2 MILLION WITH THAT BRAND.
YEAH.
AND IS IT A DESIGNED PACK?
I'M ASSUMING
IT'S NOT SMART PACK.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S -- NO.
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY.
WE MADE THIS A SEPARATE BRAND
BECAUSE WE WANTED --
IT WAS A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT CUSTOMER.
AND WE WANTED TO REACH
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
SO I'M INVESTING ONLY IN THIS,
NOT THE OTHER COMPANY.
-JUST FOR CO.ALITION.
-WE SET THAT UP FOR CO.ALITION.
IS THERE ANYTHING PROPRIETARY
ABOUT IT? DO YOU HAVE A PATENT?
NO, THERE IS NO PATENT ON THIS.
THERE IS NO PATENT, NO.
SO, BASICALLY, ANYBODY CAN PUT
A CHARGER AND A DRIVE IN A BAG.
Cuban: YEAH, THERE'S PLENTY OF
PORTABLE DRIVES THAT ARE SMALL,
THAT HAVE WIFI BUILT IN, THAT
YOU CAN ATTACH TO A CHARGER.
John:
WELL, MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THERE'S PLENTY OF BAGS
THAT HAVE A SOLAR POWER ON THEM
SO YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE TO PLUG THEM IN.
O'Leary: SO...
WELL --
WHAT DO WE GOT HERE?
NOTHING?
NO, THE DIFFERENCE IS
OUR CHARGING SYSTEM
IS ACTUALLY COMPUTERIZED.
A LOT OF THESE OTHER MOBILE
BATTERIES YOU FIND AREN'T.
WHAT'S UNIQUE?
SO, IT ACTUALLY HAS
A COMPUTER CHIP IN IT
THAT REGULATES
POWERING OUT OF THE BAG.
THE DIFFERENCE IS, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO REMOVE OUR SYSTEM.
THOSE OTHER SYSTEMS, RESEARCH
SHOWS PEOPLE USE THEM AT FIRST
AND THEN GRADUALLY
STOP USING THEM.
GUYS, HAVE YOU SOLD
ANY OF THESE YET?
YEAH, WE'VE SOLD
ALMOST 500 BAGS IN 7 MONTHS.
SO, HOW MUCH DO EACH ONE
OF THESE BAGS COST?
IT RANGES ANYWHERE
FROM $180 TO $600 RETAIL.
Herjavec:
AND WHAT'S YOUR PROFIT?
OUR PROFIT RANGE
IS ANYWHERE FROM 50% TO 70%.
-SO, JEFF, YOU'VE SOLD 500 BAGS.
-YES.
WHAT WAS YOUR TOTAL REVENUE
ON THAT?
OUR TOTAL REVENUE
IS ABOUT $100,000.
AND HOW DO PEOPLE FIND YOU?
YOU KNOW, WE'RE MAINLY SET UP
TO BE DIRECT SALES ONLINE.
-SO IT'S ALL ONLINE.
-YEAH.
YEAH,
WE HAVEN'T HAD ANY MONEY
TO PUT INTO MARKETING
OR ADVERTISING.
ALL OF THAT
HAS BEEN WORD OF MOUTH.
BUT WHAT'S THE VISION?
BESIDES --
VISION IS WHAT WE BRING
TO THE TABLE.
NO, NO, BUT HOW DO YOU SEE IT
BECOMING BIG?
HOW DO YOU --
BECAUSE THIS IS A --
THIS IS A GLOBAL PRODUCT.
WE ACTUALLY GOT THE IDEA
WHEN WE WERE IN JAPAN
ON A BUSINESS TRIP.
WE WERE ON A TRAIN,
AND WE NOTICED EVERY
SINGLE PERSON WE SAW
HAD A MOBILE DEVICE
OF SOME SORT AND A BAG.
AND THIS WORKS ACROSS THE BOARD
FOR PEOPLE TO USE.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I MEAN,
I KNOW WHAT THE GUYS ARE SAYING.
YOU CAN GO BUY ALL THAT STUFF.
BUT PEOPLE ARE LAZY.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA DO THAT.
YEAH, IT'S NOT INTEGRATED WELL.
I LOVE THE CONVENIENCE.
I PLUG MY PHONE IN.
I'M GOOD TO GO.
MM-HMM.
HERE'S YOU TODAY --
REALLY, REALLY TINY.
-YEAH.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA MAKE IT
REALLY BIG?
WHAT'S THE --
WHAT'S THE GO-TO-MARKET PLAN?
I-I FEEL LIKE THIS PRODUCT ISN'T
BEST FOR TRADITIONAL RETAIL.
BECAUSE
IT'S SO DEMONSTRABLE,
IT'S HARD TO GET RETAIL STAFF
TO BE ABLE TO REALLY --
SO YOU'RE GONNA PUMP MONEY
INTO GOING ONLINE.
YEAH.
DIRECT SALES.
YEAH, WE REALLY WANT
TO OPTIMIZE OUR WEBSITE.
YOU KNOW,
WE'RE STEPPING INTO AN ARENA
WHERE EVERYONE'S BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR, LIKE, 30 YEARS.
SO --
AND IT'S A COMMODITY.
YEAH, IT'S A VERY -- YEAH.
AND IN A PRETTY NICHE MARKET.
IT'S A VERY COMPETITIVE MARKET.
YEAH, YEAH.
SO, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE OF OUR
DESIGN, WE HAVE A FRESH OUTLOOK.
WE'RE MUCH YOUNGER,
HAVE A DIFFERENT VISION
THAN ALL THESE COMPANIES
THAT WILL LOSE THEIR LUSTER
OVER TIME.
BUT NOW
EVERY ONE OF US HERE
CAN GO PICK UP
A COUPLE OF BAGS THEY LIKE
AND SAY TO A PRIVATE LABELER,
"COPY THIS BAG,"
AND THEN THEY CAN HIRE FIVE KIDS
AT $50,000 A YEAR...
MM-HMM.
...WHO KNOWS EVERYTHING
ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND THEY CAN PRODUCE
THESE BAGS.
ALL THOSE ARE TRUE WORDS,
ACTUALLY.
YEAH, SO WHY WOULD YOU
VALUE THIS AT $1 MILLION?
I THINK 'CAUSE WE'RE PIONEERING
A MARKET HERE.
LIKE, WEARABLE TECHNOLOGY
IS EXPLODING.
GUYS, LET ME ASK
A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
IF YOU'RE SO GOOD
WITH YOUR OTHER COMPANY --
YOU'VE GROWN IT
TO $450,000 IN SALES --
WHY TAKE AWAY
ANY ATTENTION FROM IT?
THAT SCARES THE HELL OUT OF ME.
-RIGHT.
-RIGHT?
-BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A NICHE --
I MEAN,
IF YOU'RE THAT GOOD, GRIND.
YEAH.
YOU KNOW,
GET THAT FIRST COMPANY, MHM,
UP TO $1 MILLION, $2 MILLION,
$5 MILLION.
WHAT'S KEEPING YOU
FROM GETTING THERE?
BECAUSE WE SEE
THE GLOBAL POSSIBILITY
WITH THIS BRAND
MORE SO THAN MHM.
SEE,
HERE'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S LIKE,
"LET'S CREATE A NEW BRAND.
LET'S GO ON 'SHARK TANK.'
AND, OH, BY THE WAY,
WE HAVE THIS OTHER COMPANY."
I MEAN, I JUST --
IF YOU GUYS WERE GOOD,
IT WOULD HAVE JUST BEEN
ONE COMPANY.
HERE'S A NEW PRODUCT, AND
WE'RE GONNA GO TO NEW HEIGHTS.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
JEFF, YOU KNOW, I --
THIS IS NOT A SEPARATE COMPANY,
TO MARK'S POINT.
THIS IS A FEATURE
TO YOUR EXISTING COMPANY.
YOU'RE $450,000
COMPETING AGAINST
MULTI-BILLION-DOLLAR PLAYERS,
AND NOW YOU'RE GONNA STOP ONE
AND START ANOTHER?
I MEAN, IT MAKES --
WE'RE NOT STOPPING --
OH, BUT COME ON. IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE WHATSOEVER.
I THINK EVEN YOU GUYS
KNOW THAT HERE.
BUT -- BUT THE LOOK --
WHETHER YOU'RE TRYING
TO BE COY, OR...
I MEAN, THE AESTHETIC,
EVERYTHING IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN OUR --
NO, IT'S A FEATURE.
I'M OUT.
O'Leary:
OKAY, JEFF AND CASEY,
YOU HAVE THREE SHARKS
STILL IN THE DEAL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO REBOOT
AT THIS POINT?
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS RIDICULOUS.
YOU BIFURCATED
THE OTHER HALF OF SALES
AND DIDN'T BRING IT INTO
THE TANK, WHICH WAS STUPID.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO NOW?
I'M GIVING YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REBOOT.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER IDEA
YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT
BEFORE WE THROW YOU
OUT OF HERE?
♪♪
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT,
AND EVERYONE QUESTIONS
JEFF AND CASEY'S DECISION
TO ONLY OFFER THE SHARKS A STAKE
IN THEIR LESS-PROVEN
BACKPACK LINE, CO.ALITION,
AND NOT THEIR ENTIRE COMPANY,
WHICH INCLUDES
A MORE LUCRATIVE BAG LINE.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS RIDICULOUS.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO NOW?
I'M GIVING YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REBOOT.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER IDEA
YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT
BEFORE WE THROW YOU
OUT OF HERE?
♪♪
I-I WOULD BE OPEN
TO COMBINING THEM.
OOH, NO KIDDING.
YEAH.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT
I'M SAYING IS LIKE --
-SO WHAT'S YOUR OFFER FOR THAT?
-I THINK --
-I THINK THAT --
-COME ON. COME ON. LISTEN.
John: I'M ADRIAN.
YOU'RE ROCKY.
YOU CAN DO IT.
Cuban: ADRIAN!
YOU CAN DO IT, ROCKY.
WIN!
ADRIAN!
COME ON!
GIVE US AN OFFER!
SO, WE HAVE A LOT TO OFFER
BOTH SIDES OF THE FENCE,
FOR URBAN AND OUTDOOR.
WE WANT TO PUT BOTH BRANDS
ON THE TABLE,
AND WE WANT TO TRY
$300,000 FOR 30%.
Herjavec:
OF THE TOTAL COMPANY.
-OF THE TOTAL COMPANY.
-OF BOTH BRANDS, YES.
♪♪
I'M STILL OUT, GUYS.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE WILL REALLY
PAY THAT MUCH MONEY FOR THIS
WHEN THEY CAN EASILY
JUST DO IT THEMSELVES.
SO FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
I JUST FEEL THAT WE HAVE A LOT
TO OFFER TO THE BAG WORLD.
WE WORK HARD.
WE'RE YOUNG.
YOU GUYS ARE INTERESTING,
'CAUSE YOU HAVE
ALMOST $500,000 IN SALES.
THAT PROVES SOMETHING.
PEOPLE BUY YOUR BAGS.
YOU'RE WORKING HARD
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN. I GET IT.
I DON'T WANT TO
BELITTLE YOU FOR THAT,
BUT YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANYTHING THAT'S PROPRIETARY.
I SEE A BAG WITH A DRIVE
AND A BATTERY IN IT.
OKAY.
WITH INTEGRATION
THAT NOBODY ELSE IS DOING.
NO, BUT ANYBODY CAN DO IT.
LET'S BE HONEST.
BUT WE HAVE A JUMP START
ON THIS.
LISTEN, GUYS, GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
STILL GOT ONE.
YEAH.
COME ON, DAYMOND.
YEAH, SO --
SO, YOU KNOW, LISTEN.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA CREATE
ANYTHING NEW IN THIS WORLD.
YOU'RE GONNA CREATE
A NEW FORM OF DELIVERY.
EVERYTHING'S BEEN DONE.
RIGHT?
YEAH. BECAUSE WEARABLE
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN OUT.
YEAH. YEAH.
I MEAN, I THINK
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE I HAVE
IS THAT YOU HAVE ALL THE ASSETS
HERE AS HARDWORKING GUYS.
YOU'VE GROWN A COMPANY.
YOU HAVE A VISION.
BUT IT'S NOT THERE YET.
THE BAG IS NOT HOOKED UP ENOUGH.
IT'S GONNA COST A LOT TO MAKE
A LOT OF THAT EQUIPMENT
REALLY YOURS, PROPRIETARY.
I'M TEMPTED.
AND, SEE, THAT'S ALSO
WHY WE'RE HERE.
I MEAN, MORE SO
THAN THE MONEY FOR US.
WE'RE SEEKING
A STRATEGIC PARTNER...
YEAH.
...THAT WE CAN WORK WITH THAT
CAN TAKE US TO THAT NEXT LEVEL.
I'M VERY, VERY TEMPTED,
BUT MY GUT --
AND IT'S A BIG ONE --
SAYS...
AT THIS POINT, NO, I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
-GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
APPRECIATE IT.
♪♪
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
EVEN IF WE DID NOT GET A DEAL,
IT WAS REALLY COOL
TO GET THAT FEEDBACK.
WE WERE THIS CLOSE
TO GETTING HIM.
I SAW IT IN HIS EYES.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
PAT CROWLEY MADE A DEAL
WITH MARK CUBAN FOR CHAPUL, HIS
ENERGY BAR MADE WITH CRICKETS.
LET'S GO MAKE
SOME CHIRPING MONEY.
LET'S SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
OUR CRICKET BARS HAVE BEEN
HOPPING OFF THE SHELF
SINCE "SHARK TANK."
MARK HAS BEEN
A PHENOMENAL ASSET TO OUR TEAM.
WE JUST LAUNCHED IN
CENTRAL MARKET STORES IN TEXAS,
AND HE EVEN CAME OUT
TO PROMOTE OUR BARS.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL.
WE JUST CLOSED OUR BIGGEST
DEAL EVER, WITH SPROUTS.
THEY'VE AGREED TO SELL CHAPUL
IN ALL 217 LOCATIONS NATIONWIDE.
HI!
WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TRY A CRICKET BAR?
SPROUTS
IS THE FIRST MAJOR RETAILER
TO CARRY AN
INSECT-PROTEIN-BASED PRODUCT,
AND WE'RE THRILLED THAT THEY SEE
THE VALUE IN OUR PRODUCT
AND ARE WILLING
TO GIVE US A CHANCE.
NOW WE'RE IN OVER 500 STORES
IN THE UNITED STATES AND CANADA,
AND OUR HARD WORK
IS REALLY STARTING TO PAY OFF.
IT'S ACTUALLY GOOD.
WHEN I STEPPED INTO THE TANK,
WE ONLY HAD $80,000 IN SALES.
SINCE "SHARK TANK,"
WE'VE HAD $750,000,
AND WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR $1.5 MILLION THIS YEAR.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
ARE WE FEEDING THE REVOLUTION?
YEAH!
LESS THAN TWO YEARS AGO,
IT WAS JUST TWO OF US
SENDING OUT ALL THE ORDERS
FROM MY HOME OFFICE.
WE NOW HAVE A STAFF OF EIGHT,
OFFICE SPACE,
AND ARE WORKING WITH A LARGE
PROTEIN-BAR MANUFACTURER.
I STARTED CHAPUL
BECAUSE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE A HEALTHY SUPPLY
OF FOOD AND WATER
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
IS THAT BETTER, LITTLE GUY?
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, I BECAME
A FATHER FOR THE FIRST TIME.
MY WORK AT CHAPUL MEANS MORE
TO ME NOW THAN EVER.
I WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO MY PART
TO MAKE THE WORLD
A BETTER PLACE.
AND THANKS TO MARK
AND "SHARK TANK,"
CHAPUL IS REALLY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
All: FEED THE REVOLUTION!
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A UNIQUE
WAY TO KEEP COOL OUTDOORS.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
I'M JASON SHAKLEFORD,
VICE PRESIDENT OF SALES
AND MARKETING FOR ICY BREEZE.
AND MY NAME'S ANDREW JENKINS,
THE C.E.O.
AND I'M DAVE YONCE,
THE OWNER AND INVENTOR
OF THE ICY BREEZE.
TODAY,
WE'RE HERE SEEKING $50,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 5% OF OUR COMPANY.
ICY BREEZE
IS TRULY REVOLUTIONIZING
THE WAY PEOPLE DEAL
WITH THE HEAT.
WE ALL KNOW
THAT BEING HOT IS NO FUN.
AND NOW, THANKS TO ICY BREEZE,
IT IS UNNECESSARY.
ICY BREEZE
IS THE WORLD'S FIRST
PERSONAL,
PORTABLE AIR CONDITIONER
AND COOLER ALL IN ONE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AIR-CONDITIONING IS NO LONGER
JUST FOR INDOOR USE ONLY.
BECAUSE WE'RE TAKING
AIR-CONDITIONING INTO
THE GREAT OUTDOORS.
AND WE DO IT
WITH THE ICY BREEZE.
WHAT WE DO IS WE TAKE
THE ICE-COLD WATER
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE TUB,
WE PUMP THAT WATER UP INTO
THIS BRASS RADIATOR IN THE LID.
THE COLD WATER
CHILLS THE RADIATOR.
THERE'S A THREE-SPEED FAN
ALSO BUILT INTO THE LID
ON THE BACK SIDE.
THAT FAN
PULLS THE AIR OUT
AND BLOWS OUT
THROUGH THE FLEXI-HOSE
ON YOU, THE SUBJECT,
35 DEGREES BELOW
THE OUTSIDE TEMPERATURE.
I'LL TELL YOU, SHARKS,
ONE OF THE THINGS
WE ARE SO EXCITED ABOUT
IS NOT ONLY IS IT PORTABLE,
BUT IT'S WIRELESS.
THERE'S A RECHARGEABLE BATTERY
BUILT INTO THE LID
THAT PROVIDES UP TO SIX HOURS
OF COOLING RELIEF.
THE APPLICATIONS
FOR THE ICY BREEZE ARE ENDLESS.
IMAGINE BEING ABLE TO KEEP
JUNIOR COOL INSIDE THE DUGOUT
AND KEEPING MOM AND DAD COOL
IN THE STANDS IN THE BLEACHERS.
THERE ARE SO MANY
APPLICATIONS --
ICY BREEZE IS THE SOLUTION
TO BEATING THE HEAT.
O'Leary: SO, DOES THIS
MELT THE ICE FASTER
BECAUSE IT'S PUTTING
HOT AIR AGAINST IT,
IT'S RECIRCULATING?
IT DOES MELT THE ICE
A LITTLE BIT FASTER,
BUT THE LARGER CHUNK OF ICE,
THE LONGER IT'S GONNA LAST.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
RETAIL FOR THIS JEWEL
RIGHT HERE...
[ LAUGHS ]
...IS $349 JUST LIKE THIS.
-OOH-WHEE!
-WHOA!
-THAT INCLUDES --
-IS THAT ALL?
YOU CAN'T PUT A PRICE
ON COMFORT.
WELL, YOU DID -- $349.
YES, WE DID.
SO, IF I JUST BOUGHT
A REGULAR COOLER,
I THINK I COULD GET ONE
FOR ABOUT $39 TO $59.
I'VE GOT TO PAY ANOTHER $300
FOR THAT JEWEL?
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
YOU BOUGHT A CAR WITHOUT
AIR-CONDITIONING?
Cuban: YEAH, BUT YOU HAVE THREE,
FOUR, FIVE FRIENDS,
FAMILY IN THE HOT SUN IN TEXAS?
HOW'S IT GONNA KEEP
FIVE PEOPLE COLD?
-WE WANT TO SELL FIVE OF 'EM.
-NO. NO KIDDING, RIGHT?
JASON, WHY DOES IT
COST SO MUCH MORE?
BABY, YOU'RE A GREAT SALES GUY.
-IS THERE
A COST-OF-GOODS REASON?
-NO, ABSOLUTELY.
-THERE IS A COST OF GOODS.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE IT?
IT COSTS $191 TO MAKE IT.
-OH, SO IT'S EXPENSIVE
TO MANUFACTURE.
-WHOA.
-WHY IS IT SO EXPENSIVE?
-THAT'S NOT COOL.
-BECAUSE WE HAVE
A 10 AMP-HOUR
NICKEL METAL HYDRIDE BATTERY
BUILT INTO THE LID.
-WE ALL KNOW
BATTERIES ARE EXPENSIVE.
-SO THE BATTERY IS THE COST?
Cuban:
SO, HOW ARE YOU SELLING THESE?
-THE FAN, THE BRASS RADIATOR.
-YOUR MARGINS ARE HORRIBLE.
WE SELL THEM MAINLY ONLINE.
WELL,
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
WE'VE SOLD 1,700 UNITS SO FAR.
YEAH.
IN ADDITION
TO SELLING ONLINE,
WE'RE ALSO IN 48 SAM'S CLUBS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES LAST YEAR,
IN REVENUE, IN DOLLARS?
$125,000.
AND WHAT WILL YOU SELL
THIS YEAR?
THIS YEAR,
WE'RE PROJECTING $2.5 MILLION.
HOW MUCH MONEY HAVE YOU SUNK
INTO THE COMPANY ALREADY?
$5.5 MILLION.
-OOH.
-OH!
-OH.
WHY DID IT COST
$5.5 MILLION?
WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT --
-OH, IT DOES.
-SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY?
IT IS A LOT OF MONEY.
HOW DID YOU RAISE
THE $5.5 MILLION?
WHAT DID YOU PUT INTO IT?
I-I JUST PUT IT IN MYSELF.
IT'S MY MONEY.
-HOW DID YOU
MAKE ALL THAT MONEY?
-YOU HAD $5.5 MILLION TO PUT IN?
I'M A SERIAL ENTREPRENEUR.
I'VE BEEN AN ENTREPRENEUR
SINCE I WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
MY BROTHER AND I STARTED
A SOFTWARE COMPANY.
Herjavec: WHICH ONE?
SolarWinds.
YOU -- YOU STARTED SolarWinds?
YEAH.
-NO WAY!
-YOU KNOW ABOUT SolarWinds?
OH, VERY WELL.
THANKS.
YOU JUST GOT ACQUIRED,
LIKE...
SO WE STARTED THAT IN '98,
AND IT'S JUST GONE GREAT.
AND I GOT TO RING THE BELL
ON THE NEW YORK
STOCK EXCHANGE IN 2009.
I ALWAYS WANTED
TO INVENT THINGS.
I'M COMING AFTER YOU.
I'VE GOT 30-SOMETHING PATENTS.
[ LAUGHS ]
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS?
ONE NIGHT,
I WAS CAMPING WITH MY SON.
IT WAS 95 DEGREES
AT MIDNIGHT.
I'M MISERABLE.
HE'S MISERABLE.
AND OUR COOLER IS SITTING THERE
WITH DRINKS.
AND I'M LIKE, "AH, IF I COULD
JUST CRAWL INSIDE THAT THING,
IT WOULD FEEL SO GOOD."
SO WE OPEN IT UP
AND WE'RE TAKING ICE CUBES
AND RUBBING IT
ON OURSELVES.
I'M LIKE,
"THERE'S GOT TO BE A WAY
THAT I CAN COOL AIR
WITH THIS."
DIDN'T HE JUST SAY, "DAD,
SHOULDN'T WE NOT CAMP
WHEN IT'S GONNA BE 95 DEGREES
AT NIGHT?"
OH, WE'RE OUTDOORS PEOPLE.
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
I REALLY --
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR
A STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP.
-I MEAN, I'M --
-BULL CRAP.
NOT BUYING IT.
BULL CRAP.
WHY $50,000?
BECAUSE IF I CAME UP
WITH THIS HIGH EVALUATION,
I DIDN'T WANT TO BE OFFENSIVE.
BECAUSE I REALLY AM AFTER
A STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU JUST GO
AND HIRE SOMEBODY?
I MEAN, ALL OF US UP HERE
ARE AS GOOD
AS THE TEAM
THAT WE HAVE AROUND US.
WE COULD DO THAT.
WELL, THEN WHY
DON'T YOU DO THAT?
BUT IT'S CLEAR IN AMERICA
THAT THERE ARE A FEW PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THE BEST CONNECTIONS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AFTER.
Cuban: LOOK, DAVE,
THAT MAKES PERFECT SENSE, RIGHT?
I'VE FUNDED
PASSION PROJECTS MYSELF.
AND REALLY,
YOU'RE BLESSED LIKE I AM
WHERE IT'S NOT
ABOUT HOW BIG THE CHECK IS.
RIGHT.
IT'S ABOUT
ACCOMPLISHING SOMETHING
AND THEN JUST PROVING
YOU CAN DO IT AGAIN.
YEAH. AND PEOPLE
THAT ACTUALLY WORK HARD.
BUT THE CHALLENGE IS ONCE
YOU'VE GOTTEN THAT BIG CHECK,
IS YOU LOSE SOME OF
THE PISS AND VINEGAR, RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE I HAD
A SEMI-LONG-TERM GIRLFRIEND,
AND SHE SAID,
"IT'S ME OR YOUR COMPANY,"
AND MY RESPONSE WAS,
"WHAT WAS YOUR NAME AGAIN?"
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU KNOW?
YOU'RE ALL-IN. YOU'RE FOCUSED.
YOU'RE DRIVEN.
ONCE YOU GET
THAT BIG CHECK,
EVEN THOUGH YOU THINK YOU CAN
RECAPTURE IT ALL THE TIME,
IT'S HARD,
BECAUSE FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE,
I WANT THE ENTREPRENEUR
TO HAVE THAT UNLIMITED DRIVE.
AND I THINK YOUR WING MEN
PROBABLY HAVE A LOT OF IT.
BUT I DON'T THINK
THERE'S A SHORTCUT HERE FROM ME
FOR YOU TO GET THERE.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
Herjavec: DAVE,
DO YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE?
DO YOU THINK YOU'RE AS DRIVEN
TODAY AS YOU WERE BEFORE?
I DON'T THINK
I'LL EVER BE AS DRIVEN,
BUT I DO IT
IN 10 DIFFERENT WAYS NOW.
ALL OF MY BUSINESSES
ARE CASH-FLOW-POSITIVE.
ALL OF THEM ARE A SUCCESS.
I MEAN, I JUST -- I LOVE IT.
WE ARE STABLE.
WE ARE CASH-FLOW-POSITIVE.
THE RISK IS GONE.
I THINK -- WELL, NO,
THE RISK IS NOT GONE.
NO, NOT GONE.
I THINK, DAVE,
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
IT'S THE TIME THAT IT TAKES
TO GIVE YOU WHAT YOU NEED
BECAUSE THAT TIME
I'M TAKING AWAY
FROM ONE OF
MY EXISTING BUSINESSES.
YOU DON'T NEED US.
IF YOU WALK OUT OF HERE,
YOU WILL BE TOTALLY FINE.
AND I DON'T HAVE THE TIME
TO HELP ANOTHER GUY WHO --
YOU MAY EVEN BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL THAN ME.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
FAIR ENOUGH.
SO, DAVE, I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE IN AMERICA
ARE GONNA EMBRACE
A $400 COOLER WITH ICE IN IT
AS AN AIR CONDITIONER,
SO I'M OUT.
YOU -- YOU'RE CLEARLY NOT
AN OUTDOORSY PERSON.
I AM AN OUTDOORSY PERSON,
BUT I LIKE A MINT ON MY PILLOW
EVERY NIGHT.
YEAH. DAVE,
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
WE HAVE A SEGMENT
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
PORTABLE,
PERSONAL AIR-CONDITIONING
DOESN'T EXIST TODAY.
WE ARE IT.
DAVE,
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE.
YOU WOULD HAVE NEVER BUILT
THIS COOLER FOR $350
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THE KIND OF MONEY YOU HAVE.
WE WANT IT TO BE NOT JUST
A GREAT AIR CONDITIONER,
BUT WE WANT IT TO BE
ONE OF THE BEST COOLERS.
THERE'S NO WAY
THIS IS GONNA SELL
ON A WIDE SCALE FOR 350 BUCKS.
I JUST THINK THE PRICE POINT
IS TOO HIGH.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LOWER IT.
GOOD LUCK ON YOUR JOURNEY.
I'M OUT.
LISTEN, IT'S A CLEVER SOLUTION
TO THE HEAT,
BUT THE ONE THING I WORRY ABOUT
IT IS, IT BLASTS AT ONE PERSON.
WE FIND FAMILIES
AT THE BALL FIELDS USING IT
WHERE THEY SIT
AND THEY BLOW IT THIS WAY,
AND TWO OR THREE PEOPLE
ARE ENJOYING --
BUT IT'S REALLY EXPENSIVE.
BUT RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE PAYING
$349 RIGHT AND LEFT FOR IT.
WELL, YOU DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HISTORY YET.
BECAUSE
IT'S A BRAND-NEW PRODUCT.
IT'S A BRAND-NEW MARKET.
YOU'RE INVENTIVE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
ONLY A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF THE POPULATION
CAN AFFORD TO BUY THAT
TO BRING WITH THEM.
I THINK IT'S A CLEVER SOLUTION,
BUT I'M OUT.
-THANKS, GUYS.
-WE'RE ALL OUT.
THANKS.
APPRECIATE IT.
-GOOD LUCK. KEEP CREATING.
-YOU GUYS TAKE CARE.
♪♪
Yonce: IT'S BAFFLING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T COME ON BOARD.
I MEAN, WE HAVE ALL OF
OUR TOOLING PAID FOR.
WE'RE CASH-FLOW-POSITIVE.
WE'RE DEBT-FREE.
IT'S JUST MIND-BOGGLING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T COME ON BOARD.
MY NAME IS SHAAN PATEL,
AND I'M FROM LAS VEGAS, NEVADA.
TODAY, LET'S START OUT
WITH THIS SIMPLE PROBLEM.
I'VE DEVELOPED
AN EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
THAT HELPS STUDENTS
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS
WHETHER IT'S GETTING INTO
THE COLLEGE THEY WANT TO,
THE SCHOLARSHIPS THEY WANT TO,
AND JUST BE THE BEST
THAT THEY CAN BE.
MY PARENTS GREW UP VERY POOR
IN GUJARAT, INDIA,
AND THEY IMMIGRATED TO AMERICA
WITH JUST $65 IN THEIR POCKETS.
THROUGH HARD WORK,
THEY WERE ABLE TO
SAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO OPEN A BUDGET MOTEL.
THAT'S WHERE I GREW UP.
HI, MOM. HI, DAD.
MY PARENTS INSTILLED IN ME
THE VALUE OF EDUCATION.
BECAUSE OF MY HARD WORK,
I ENDED UP GETTING
A FULL-RIDE SCHOLARSHIP
TO THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE I'M CURRENTLY
GETTING MY MEDICAL DEGREE.
AT THE SAME TIME,
I'M DOING MY MBA AT YALE.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
WELCOME TO CLASS TODAY.
NOW I NEED A SHARK
TO HELP ME TAKE MY BUSINESS
TO THE NATIONAL LEVEL.
WITH THE SHARK'S INVESTMENT,
I BELIEVE I CAN HELP
MILLIONS OF STUDENTS ACHIEVE
SUCCESS JUST LIKE I HAVE.
IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO SUCCEED
BECAUSE MY PARENTS
HAVE INVESTED SO MUCH IN ME,
AND I WANT TO MAKE THEM PROUD.
MY SUCCESS
IS THEIR AMERICAN DREAM.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS SHAAN PATEL.
I'M FROM LAS VEGAS, NEVADA,
AND I'M SEEKING $250,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY,
2400 EXPERT S.A.T. PREP.
SO, WE ALL KNOW MEN LIE,
WOMEN LIE, BUT NUMBERS DON'T.
SO LET ME GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS.
SINCE 2005, 14 MILLION STUDENTS
HAVE TAKEN THE S.A.T.
AND ONLY 3,000 HAVE GOTTEN
A PERFECT 2400.
THAT'S JUST .02%.
AND I HAPPEN TO BE
ONE OF THOSE 3,000.
SO I KNOW YOU MIGHT BE THINKING,
"OH, YOU'RE JUST SOME GENIUS.
HOW CAN YOU HELP
OTHER STUDENTS?"
BUT I AM BY NO MEANS A GENIUS.
ACTUALLY, THE FIRST TIME
I TOOK THE S.A.T. EXAM,
I ONLY SCORED AROUND AVERAGE.
BUT AFTER DILIGENTLY
SELF-STUDYING FOR THIS TEST,
I WAS ABLE TO RAISE MY SCORE
640 POINTS TO A PERFECT 2400.
NOW, I'M SHARING
MY TEST-PREP SECRETS
TO HELP OTHER STUDENTS PREPARE
THE WAY I DID IN HIGH SCHOOL.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
ADMITTED TO IVY-LEAGUE SCHOOLS,
HAVE WON MILLIONS
IN COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS,
AND SOME HAVE EVEN GOTTEN
PERFECT S.A.T. SCORES
THEMSELVES.
NOW, 2400 EXPERT IS LOOKING
TO EXPAND ACROSS THE NATION.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY TO
SCORE BIG OFF MY PERFECT SCORE?
WOW.
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU.
TELL US HOW IT WORKS.
IT'S A SIX-WEEK COURSE.
AND UP UNTIL
JUST ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO,
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN IN-PERSON,
CLASSROOM-STYLE IN LAS VEGAS.
WE JUST STARTED OFFERING
ONLINE COURSES SIX MONTHS AGO.
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
STARTING TO BRING IN
MORE REVENUE THAN EVEN
THE IN-PERSON COURSES.
WHAT'S THE REVENUE TODAY?
SO, WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS,
AND WE'VE DONE
$1.2 MILLION IN SALES.
WOW.
THAT'S IN
THE TOTAL PERIOD, RIGHT?
THAT'S IN THE TOTAL PERIOD,
BUT WHAT'S REALLY EXCITING
ABOUT THAT IS
PRETTY MUCH EVERY YEAR,
WE'VE DOUBLED REVENUE,
SO ABOUT HALF OF
THAT $1.2 MILLION
CAME JUST LAST YEAR,
BASED ON LAS VEGAS
IN-PERSON COURSES.
SO, SHAAN, HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS.
YEAH?
I KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
THE TEST-PREP MARKET.
OKAY.
I WAS A SHAREHOLDER IN KAPLAN
AND THE PRINCETON REVIEW.
THERE WE GO. YEAH.
BOTH OF THEM.
TELL ME, WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO ACQUIRE A STUDENT?
SO, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
WE DON'T HAVE GREAT ANALYTICS
ON THE CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION
COST.
BUT WHAT I CAN TELL YOU
IS PRETTY MUCH
ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS
COME FROM WORD OF MOUTH,
SO IT'S PARENTS AND STUDENTS
WHO HAVE HEARD
ABOUT OUR SCORE IMPROVEMENTS.
I GET THAT
FOR THE LAS VEGAS MARKET.
YEAH.
BUT IF YOU
WANT TO SCALE THIS
AND COMPETE WITH THE BIG BOYS
IN TEST PREP,
YOU NEED TO FIGURE OUT
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY SPEND ALL THEIR TIME DOING.
YES.
NO, NO, I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND WE'RE DEFINITELY
WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW.
SHAAN,
WHAT DOES THE COURSE COST?
SO, THE IN-PERSON COURSE
COSTS --
FOR A 60-HOUR COURSE
COSTS $999.
SO, THAT COMES OUT
TO ABOUT $17 PER HOUR.
AND WHAT IS THE COST
ONLINE?
ONLINE, IT'S $599
FOR THOSE 60 HOURS,
SO UNDER $10 AN HOUR.
SO, ON THE 600,000 SALES
LAST YEAR,
HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU MAKE?
WE MADE ABOUT $220,000.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THAT
IS ONLINE CURRICULUM?
WE JUST STARTED
6 MONTHS AGO ONLINE,
SO ABOUT 40%
IS NOW BRINGING ONLINE.
SO NOW WE HAVE STUDENTS
ENROLLING
FROM CHINA, INDIA, LONDON --
AND IS ONLINE LIVE?
WILL YOU STILL HAVE
AN INSTRUCTOR,
OR IS ONLINE RECORDED
AND PACKAGED?
YEAH, SO I'M PRETTY MUCH
THE FACE OF THE COMPANY.
AND A LOT OF STUDENTS
WANT TO TAKE COURSES WITH ME,
SO I TEACH ONE COURSE A WEEK
FOR ONLINE.
SO I'LL TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY BACKGROUND.
SURE.
I'M CURRENTLY AN MD/MBA STUDENT
AT BOTH U.S.C. AND YALE.
WOW.
AND THE REASON
THAT I AM WHERE I AM TODAY
IS REALLY BECAUSE
OF MY S.A.T. SCORE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
MY S.A.T. SCORE CHANGED MY LIFE.
I GREW UP
IN MY PARENTS' BUDGET MOTEL.
I WENT TO URBAN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN THE WORST SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE NATION.
BUT BECAUSE OF MY S.A.T. SCORE,
I WAS ADMITTED
INTO PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITIES.
I RECEIVED $500,000
IN SCHOLARSHIP OFFERS.
I EVEN GOT TO MEET THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
O'Leary:
WHY DOES 2400 EXPERT
GET THE INCREMENTAL STUDENT
THAT'S NEVER HEARD OF YOU?
WE HAVE AN AVERAGE
S.A.T. SCORE IMPROVEMENT
THAT'S INDUSTRY-LEADING --
376 POINTS IN 6 WEEKS.
THAT'S COMPARED
TO OUR COMPETITORS,
WHO GET 50 TO 100.
SO, THE PRODUCT'S GOOD
IS WHAT YOU'RE TELLING ME.
BUT HOW DO I LET THE --
THE PRODUCT'S GREAT, YEAH.
HOW DO I LET THE WORLD KNOW
THAT YOU EVEN EXIST?
BECAUSE THE WHOLE STRATEGY
OF THE S.A.T. MARKET
IS CUSTOMER ACQUISITION --
IT'S THE WHOLE DEAL.
OR, BETTER YET, WHAT ARE
YOU GONNA USE THE MONEY FOR?
YES, SO,
THE MONEY IS GONNA BE USED
TO OPEN A DOZEN NEW LOCATIONS.
SO THE MARKETS
THAT I'VE SELECTED ARE NEW YORK,
LOS ANGELES, SAN FRANCISCO,
WASHINGTON D.C., PHILADELPHIA,
AND BOSTON.
BUT NOW YOUR ONLINE OPERATION
IS YOU TEACHING LIVE.
THAT'S ONE. WE COULD ALWAYS HAVE
OTHER INSTRUCTORS TEACHING LIVE.
BUT WE HAVE ALSO
ENROLLED STUDENTS.
OKAY, BUT DOES IT NEED
TO BE LIVE ALL THE TIME?
WHAT'S THAT?
OR COULD IT BE
PACKAGED CONTENT?
-OH, SO THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
-RIGHT.
EVERYONE -- SO, OUR CUSTOMER
IS NOT THE HIGH-SCHOOL STUDENT.
IT'S THE HIGH-SCHOOL PARENT.
AND PARENTS DO NOT WANT
THE PRE-RECORDED ONLINE COURSE
FOR THEIR HIGH-SCHOOL STUDENT
IN GENERAL.
I'M CURRENTLY IN THE ONLINE
EDUCATIONAL SPACE.
NOW, YOU BROUGHT UP
A VERY GOOD POINT --
THE PARENTS ARE BUYING IT
AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE KIDS THEMSELVES
TAKE IT,
BUT THEY DON'T BELIEVE
THEY'RE GONNA GO AND SIT DOWN
IN FRONT OF THE COMPUTER
EVERY DAY.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T SEE THE SCALABILITY
IN REGARDS TO WHERE
I CAN HELP YOU WITH MY MODEL.
MM-HMM.
I CAN'T TAKE THIS RIDE WITH YOU,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
APPRECIATE THAT.
DO YOU WANT TO
BE A DOCTOR?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO BE A DOCTOR.
OR AN ENTREPRENEUR?
UH, THIS -- LOOK.
I'VE -- SO I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN IN SCHOOL.
I'VE ALWAYS -- SO, THAT'S A --
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN IN SCHOOL,
BUT I'VE ALSO ALWAYS
BEEN AN ENTRE--
SHAAN, I THINK YOU'RE DIGGING
YOURSELF A HOLE HERE.
BECAUSE AN INVESTOR,
A SHARK INVESTOR,
WANTS TO HEAR
THAT YOU'RE TOTALLY COMMITTED
TO DOMINATING
THE TEST-PREP SPACE.
YEAH.
AND IT HAS TO BE OOZING
FROM EVERY PORE.
WE HAVE TO BELIEVE IT.
♪♪
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT,
AND THE SHARKS QUESTION
SHAAN'S COMMITMENT
TO HIS BUSINESS, 2400 EXPERT,
AN S.A.T. PREP COURSE.
DO YOU WANT TO
BE A DOCTOR?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED
TO BE A DOCTOR.
OR AN ENTREPRENEUR?
UH, THIS -- LOOK.
YOU CAN'T BE
A PART-TIME ENTREPRENEUR.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE SOMEBODY
DRIVING THE BUSINESS.
AND YOU HAVEN'T
ARTICULATED
A STRATEGY
FOR CUSTOMER ACQUISITION.
OKAY. SO I'LL GIVE YOU --
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXACT STRATEGY.
SO, YES, I'M IN MEDICAL SCHOOL.
I REALIZED IN MEDICAL SCHOOL
THAT MY BUSINESS WAS TAKING OFF.
WE BARELY HAD ENOUGH STUDENTS
FOR THE FIRST COURSE.
WHAT I'M DOING IS FOCUSING
ON MY BUSINESS TO SCALE IT.
I'M TAKING AN EXTENDED SUMMER
JUST TO FOCUS ON MY BUSINESS.
I THINK THAT THE ELECTRONIC
CONTENT IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
I UNDERSTAND YOU SAY
THAT PEOPLE WON'T SIT AND DO IT,
BUT I THINK
THAT IF YOU HAVE PARENTS
AND YOU'RE A STUDENT
THAT REALLY CARES,
EVEN IF JUST
A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE STICK,
AND YOU CAN SELL A LOT
OF THE ELECTRONIC CONTENT,
THEN THAT'S THE WAY
YOU'RE REALLY GONNA
DRIVE THIS BUSINESS.
BUT I -- YOU KNOW, ENTREPRENEUR,
DOCTOR, YOU'RE NOT SURE.
I DON'T SEE ME GIVING YOU
THE MONEY TO SUPPORT THIS.
I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU KNOW WHICH
DIRECTION YOU WANT TO BE.
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANKS.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
OKAY. UM,
LET ME TAKE A SHOT AT IT.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MENTION
THAT I WOULD BE OPEN, KEVIN,
TO A LICENSING DEAL
WITH PRINCETON REVIEW OR KAPLAN.
IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE INTERESTING TO ANY SHARK.
YEAH, I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY DO THAT.
THEY FEEL PRETTY CONFIDENT
ABOUT THEIR CONTENT.
YEAH, NO, OF COURSE.
I WAS JUST THROWING IT OUT.
Herjavec:
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
I THINK YOU COULD SELL
A LOT OF IT.
BUT MY CHALLENGE WITH IT IS
YOU'RE KIND OF PLAYING AT IT.
YOU WANT TO BE A DOCTOR,
AND YOU WANT TO BE
AN ENTREPRENEUR.
AND THEN WHEN KEVIN ASKED YOU,
YOU SAID,
"OH, I'D ALSO BE INTERESTED
IN MAYBE LICENSING IT."
YOU KNOW, BUSINESS ISN'T THAT.
YOU CAN'T PLAY AT BUSINESS.
WELL, I --
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA
COME ACROSS A GUY
WHO DOESN'T WANT
TO BE A DOCTOR,
AND HE IS GOING TO
KICK YOUR BEHIND.
I CAN'T INVEST
IN A PART-TIME ENTREPRENEUR.
I'M OUT.
THE GREAT THING
ABOUT THIS MARKET
THAT I'VE KNOWN FOR YEARS,
IT'S RECESSION-PROOF.
YEAH.
AND IT'S HUGE.
YOUR BIGGEST PROBLEM, SHAAN,
IS YOU'RE NOT 110% COMMITTED.
THE QUALITY OF ENTREPRENEUR
THAT GETS ON THAT CARPET
HAS TO BE SO COMMITTED
BEFORE THEY GET A CHECK
FROM A SHARK.
MM-HMM.
I GIVE MY MONEY TO PEOPLE THAT
WILL DIE FOR THEIR BUSINESS.
THEY'LL GIVE UP
THEIR LIVES FOR IT.
THAT'S THE KIND OF GENERAL
I WANT TO BACK.
YOU'RE NOT
THAT KIND OF GENERAL.
I'M OUT.
Cuban:
UM, LOOK, REALLY, WHERE DO
YOU WANT TO BE IN 10 YEARS?
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
BECAUSE YOU WILL GET BORED
WITH THIS.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THIS BE
A $20 MILLION REVENUE BUSINESS.
BUT MY DREAM IS ALSO,
I WOULD LOVE
TO BE A DERMATOLOGIST
OR OPHTHALMOLOGIST
WHO WORKS TWICE A WEEK.
[ LAUGHS ]
I BELIEVE I'M THE
HARDEST-WORKING PERSON I KNOW
OTHER THAN MY FATHER.
MY FATHER CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
WITH, LIKE, $65.
HE WORKED FROM 5:00 A.M.
TO 11:00 P.M.,
SPLITTING HIS TIME
BETWEEN A PHARMACY,
GAS STATION, AND MOTEL.
AND I GOT MY WORK ETHIC
FROM HIM. I'VE WORKED --
LOOK, ONE OF THE BEAUTIES
OF "SHARK TANK" --
AND PEOPLE -- THESE GUYS
ALWAYS GIVE ME A HARD TIME
WHEN I DO THIS...
YEAH.
...IS YOU GET TO ACQUI-HIRE
ALL THE TIME,
WHERE MORE OFTEN THAN NOT,
YOU'RE BETTING
ON THE BRAINS IN THE COMPANY.
YEAH.
SO I LIKE OPPORTUNITIES
LIKE THIS.
BUT I HAVE QUESTIONS,
ALL RIGHT?
OKAY.
SO, WHAT I WANT TO KNOW, THEN,
IS IF YOU PIVOT...
YEAH.
THAT WHATEVER YOU GO IN,
EXCLUSIVE OF MEDICINE, RIGHT,
THIS ALL BECOMES
PART OF THE RIDE.
OF COURSE.
THIS IS ALWAYS PART OF THE RIDE.
THIS IS MY MAIN THING.
IT'S MY BABY.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT,
BUT IF YOUR BABY EXPANDS
AND YOU HAVE OTHER CHILDREN...
YEAH.
I WANT -- I WANT TO BE THE
GODPARENT TO THOSE CHILDREN.
YOU WOULD OF COURSE
BE THE GODPARENT.
SO WHAT I'LL DO IS
I'LL OFFER YOU THE $250K
FOR 20%.
UM...I-I THINK
THAT CONTINGENCY'S FINE.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE
A COUNTEROFFER.
OH.
15%, SO MEET IN HALFWAY THERE,
$300,000.
NO.
OH.
NOT --
NO, BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GONNA BE THE GUY,
THE BIGGEST NEED YOU HAVE
IS INFRASTRUCTURE...
YEAH.
...AND TAKING OFF
ALL THE ADMINISTRIVIA.
IT'S, UH...
COULD WE DO $300,000 FOR 20%?
NOPE.
OH!
YOU KEEP DROPPING YOU PISTOL
WHEN YOU JUMP
THROUGH THE WINDOW.
YOU CAME IN
AT $250,000 FOR 10%.
WHY ARE YOU DOING THAT?
-WAIT, NO --
-NOW YOU'RE GOING $300,000 --
ALL RIGHT,
I TAKE YOUR OFFER, MARK.
DONE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
-THANKS.
-THANK YOU.
-APPRECIATE IT.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
-YES, WE WILL.
THANKS. APPRECIATE IT.
IMPRESSIVE.
YES, YES!
OH, YES.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
MARK CUBAN
IS MY BUSINESS PARTNER.
THAT'S -- THAT'S PRETTY COOL.